terry what memories has this film
brought back of working with the pythons
and what do you think graeme would have
made in the movie
um i think graham would have loved the
movie and uh
because it's so scatty and it's so uh
bitty and uh
and wonderful um
and uh
um yeah the the memories it brought back
um
yeah so
it just felt natural actually to hear
graham's voice and
just felt like old heart
what was it like being directed by your
son as well
well he's actually directed me a couple
of other times actually um so
so it was
it was again perfectly natural
he's very nice he's a very nice man
actually and he's uh he uh he's he's
just great actually
you